that was very beautiful but maybe hair
of it I understood zero percent of that
hi I'm sweaty
hi I'm Jenny and today we're gonna be
identifying Indian languages this might
be really embarrassing but we'll see
yeah I don't know that I'm gonna do that
well yes because there's so much there's
so many there's there's 22 I think
official languages so I'm Indian and
Filipino and I grew up speaking English
my mom speaks a lungo and Tagalog and my
dad speaks Hindi but mostly Gujarati
that's falling I know I know and I
didn't get to learn any of them just
basic words my parents are from othor
Pradesh and they taught me Hindi and
English growing up all right I guess
let's bring person number one in yeah
give it a try
I don't want to offend anyone all right
so we're gonna blindfold ourselves to
heighten our senses oh I'm so anxious
already
[Music]
[Music]
hi no that's very pretty
thank you can you say more things
rhondella pure Americana no in Chloe
mañana a guru
Ibaka mark Ladner ooh I'm getting a good
over qu e bar SHINee British fellow
Italian of the East Ontario um it sounds
really nice and I really wish I could
understand more of it also she's a great
voice oh yeah very soothing voice it's
definitely not Gujarati and I don't
think it's Hindi so that narrows down
not very much so I have friends who
speak Kannada and I don't want to say it
sounds similar this is not similar at
all Canada [ __ ] estate low-margin
I didn't understand any of that um
Bengali I'll also go with Bengali
absolutely nothing she says yeah she's
upstate so and that doesn't really
really help I have friends from South
India okay and they like they do speak
gonna turn up mhm
and it's it does sound kind of similar
is there any sort of like overlapping so
the four languages in South India that
are primarily spoken Kannada they'll go
with them and my album and they are all
in like four states around there I lived
in India for a couple of years and when
you go to school there they like force
you to learn three languages pretty like
fluently but right now I would say I'm
only like confident in English and
Telugu so one way to say goodbye and
I'll do is ballesta which means like
I'll see you again later okay
or ever lost um which means welcome back
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi India may totally spur t-shirt look
is partially but contains a better look
North India may is partially basket a
miracle me hum Hindi member hot sorry
but Eckert am a Papa he shot Mohini me
vodka team or me Bengali atone case odd
man Bengali my basket
gee this is yep Sawasdee is responding
and she said she perfect we love to see
it a lot of our family still lives back
in India so we don't have a ton of
family who lives in the US and so we
feel FOMO with all of our other family
members always hang out so I always go
back to see like my cousins and my
grandparents and it's super fun and so I
think my Hindi definitely like improved
because growing up I just went a ton you
were saying like the bigger words you
know cuz like I speak conversationally
yeah I've had like obviously you know it
was my mom in my uber this morning where
I was like mom how do I say like
national government how do I say like 44
and she was like I can't her calm down
and like so I don't actually speak like
this great so shots my mom how do you
say nice to meet you in cool milk a
cushy we've a car milk wake
[Music]
hi hello are you guys good good thanks
I'm good I'm gonna ROV
I mean cockeyed armoire you see I'm the
icon in Los Angeles lucky
I mean Bible tour last year got the
watch allow me UC Berkeley Graduate
course II that was very beautiful and I
said maybe a hair of it I understood 0%
of that I mean mohini so Jake an amateur
movie so can a shock wave hashtag out
her wallet economic both the party but a
bishop Harlow Cuadra Volta Karina so our
main J language I'm makin Casa Bonita
posh I gotta really English you know
what's weird I understand some of this
oh yeah there's a bit of it I feel like
I'm
what are you understand I'm
understanding Pasha is language someone
was 8 your little brother
chortle by M hmm that overlaps a little
hungry were though is something I think
of but this doesn't sound to me like or
Google but I could be wrong cuz like
what do I know
they all sound varies they're like
dialects but also you said that the
place where it's spoken hasn't overlap
with the name itself the language is
what they what so that's why I'm like
thank me this is Bengali um yeah let's
go with that
hello
this is definitely pingali so you got it
yeah yeah I realized there was like an
overlap with oh my gosh it's very very
similar I grew up speaking both because
they're so close I couldn't say grew up
in Bangladesh because that would get
anywhere yeah and then it's began in
West Bengal which I also could not say
because I'm giving it away do you know
whether they both maybe came from son
skirt there so yes there I think most of
those Indian language is at direct from
semester that's why they sound so
familiar Sanskrit is an ancient language
and a lot of languages were pulled from
it basically it was the base language
that was spoken many many many years ago
unlike there's some people who still
speak it but not so much anymore it's
been parsed out through different
languages it's it's supposed to be like
one of the most beautiful languages
and I would if I could like figure out
how to read it or learn anything about
it I would like one word can mean like a
whole paragraph of meaning which is so
incredible so most people will just say
goodbye but if you want to do it there
of the traditional way people say Salaam
it's means God peace be upon you or like
God be with you in Arabic because a lot
of people in Bangladesh are Muslim and
so that's what we say we say Salaam all
right it was great meeting you guys
really cool very challenging yeah
usually I would have been like oh maybe
this has got it up maybe this is
thummell maybe this is Telugu and I
didn't do I only did one of those guess
isn't that I freaked out we got two out
of three though so that's not too bad no
it's not shabby
I learned that Bengali and Hindi have an
overlap I thought it was really
interesting that there's a lot of Arabic
intertwined in that language too so I
didn't know that it was like borderline
ASMR because they all spoke so
eloquently and so it was so calming a
lot of people don't really know that
there are so many different languages in
India so it is really fascinating to be
able to hear some of the ones that I
actually have never heard I can't
necessarily tell them all apart but they
all sound great
[Music]
you